I wish I had wings maybe someday you
will there are plenty of animated movies
from years ago that are still really
popular today but there's also lots of
awesome animated films that don't get
enough credit we're bringing you 25 of
the most underrated forgotten movies
that gen Z might never have heard of
keep watching to the end to discover a
movie that has social distancing as a
theme with all this extra time on our
hands we'll be able to watch them all
let my people go
if you want to see an alternative to the
typical Disney Princess take a look at
Atlantis the lost Empire the 2001 Disney
movie stars kita a warrior princess
that's no damsel in distress the story
follows young adventurer Milo thatch and
his fellow explorers on their quest to
find the lost continent of Atlantis if
you love it there's a 2003
straight-to-video sequel to who are you
on the subject of princesses fans of the
Disney franchise should watch it the
Swan Princess to nest family
entertainment and rich Animation Studios
made this 1994 movie which is probably
why it's not as well known as its Disney
counterparts it tells the rocky love
story of princess Odette and Prince
Derek the evil Lord
Rothbart and a swan spell there are
several straight-to-video sequels - if
you get hooked
this 1997 movie from Fox animation
studio has a starry voice cast it
includes meg Ryan John Cusack
Christopher Lloyd Kirsten Dunst Kelsey
Grammer and Hank Azaria and it follows
the eponymous heroine Anastasia as she
tries to escape from freaky villain
Rasputin and henchman Bartok
it's a classic rags to riches story with
plenty of songs and the Russian royal
family what more could you want Don
Bluth the directed it and he's
responsible for many of our entries
another dog Bluth creation Thumbelina
tells the tale of the tiny thumb-sized
girl Jodi Benson provides her voice
she's most famous as the voice behind
Ariel in the Little Mermaid so there's
reason enough to watch but the plot is
fun too Thumbelina meets a fairy Prince
who saves her from the creatures of the
woods like the kidnapping tones this
1994 Warner Brothers film is perfect for
fans of fairy films and so is our next
entry Fern Gully the last rain forest is
worth watching for Robin Williams's turn
as the voice of a bat alone nobody cares
about me I do Batman
but there are lots of other reasons to
love this fairy film from 1992 not least
it's strong environmental message it's
about how the magical inhabitants of a
rain forest to fight to save their home
from logging and pollution Tim Curry and
Christian Slater provide voices there's
a 1998 sequel to which follows the
fairies on their mission to rescue young
animals from poachers if it's adventure
that you're after then look no further
than the road to El Dorado this movie
from the year 2000 follows two con
artists voiced by Kevin Kline and
Kenneth Branagh off on their quest for
riches the scammers get their hands on a
map to the City of Gold after getting
lost at sea they end up finding the
fabled El Dorado and the feisty Chao
voiced by Rosie Perez my only wish is to
serve the gods
The Emperor's New Groove is another
adventure story from the year 2000 but
this time from Disney despite its famous
studio credentials this comedy is often
forgotten but it's definitely worthy of
your attention
watch as the vain Emperor Kuzco voiced
by David Spade tries to destroy a
village to build a water park watch as
he's turned into a llama in a botched
plot by yzma voiced by Eartha Kitt and
then he has to enlist the help of lowly
llama her pocha voiced by John Goodman
it's as wacky as it sounds we can figure
this out I hate you while you're in an
adventure mood you'll want to give the
sci-fi Treasure Planet a try this 2002
Disney movie takes the premise of
Treasure Island but sets it in outer
space expect alien worlds and
out-of-this-world entertainment as we
follow rebel hero Jim Hawkins
voiced by Joseph gordon-levitt I think I
just found your mind hold still
it's a slacker turned hero tale that
doesn't get the recognition it deserves
we've covered princesses fairies and
adventures so now it's the animals turn
we're going all the way back to 1974
this Disney classic into the jazz cafes
of Paris you'll fall in love with smooth
talk and Tomcat Thomas O'Malley long of
seeking you who helps Duchess and her
kittens Berlioz Toulouse and Marie the
Aristocats has a kidnap plot or should
we say catnap plot that's perfect for
fans of 101 Dalmatians sticking with
cats Oliver and company from 1988
features the coolest stray Kitty you'll
ever see the story was inspired by
Charles Dickens's novel Oliver Twist and
this Oliver is a homeless kitten who
falls in with the wrong crowd in New
York a group of dogs led by Dodger who
steal to survive but Oliver's life is
transformed when he meets rich girl
Jenny
speaking of dogs if you love hounds then
you'll seriously love lady in the [ __ ]
this Disney movie from 1995 is probably
one of the better known films on our
list but it doesn't get anywhere near
the hype it deserves telling the love
story of the two eponymous canine heroes
it's got stellar songs and an iconic
spaghetti kiss moment nearly 50 years
later they made a sequel about the
couple's son I'm gonna be the best
junkyard dog there everyone and in 2019
there was a live-action remake the
pebble and the penguin is a must watch
for anyone who loves a good love story
it's about an introverted penguin called
Hubie he has to present his betrothal
pebble to the love of his life before
the festival is over but plenty of drama
stands in his way we mentioned Don Bluth
earlier and he's listed as an uncredited
director on this 1995 movie he was an
assistant animator on early Disney films
like the sword in the stone and a
character animator on the likes of Robin
Hood more on both of those movies coming
right up that was just a bit of a lock
little job the famous legend got the
Disney treatment in this 1973 movie
animals play the parts with foxes as the
eponymous hero and Maid Marion a bear as
Little John and a badger as Friar Tuck
the rest of the Sherwood Forest crew are
there too as they battled the greedy
lion Prince John voiced by Sir Peter
Ustinov stealing from the rich to give
to the poor is still as relevant as ever
you might have heard of Disney's 1977
animation the rescuers but have you
heard of the rescuers down under those
adorable mice came back from another
adventure in this 1991 sequel set in
Australia the Ras agents miss Bianca and
Bernard are out to save a little boy and
a Golden Eagle in this watch worthy
installment we've covered cats dogs mice
woodland creatures and even penguins so
next up is horses the 2002 movie spirit
stallion of the Cimarron introduced
viewers to the wild stallion of the
title
oh yes although captured by humans the
horse refuses to let go of his dream to
return home to the herd if you love
spirit riding free on Netflix then
you'll want to watch the original that
inspired it
we're back with Don Bluth and the Disney
retelling of the famous Arthurian legend
you think that a movie featuring the
iconic wizard Merlin would be more
popular but perhaps it's 1960s animation
style keeps it in the shade we think its
style is a big part of its charm if you
love the animation look of Sleeping
Beauty which Don Bluth also worked on
then you'll love this tale of English
history and madam MIM is an excellent
villain my pretties another dog Bluth
offering this time with an environmental
message that fans of Fern Gully will
appreciate when an evil queen banished
is the kind hearted flower loving troll
Stanley to New York City he befriends
two little kids in Central Park it's
worth watching for its ultimate thumb
Russel alone Stanley's green one against
the Evil Queen's stone turning thumb on
the magical creatures theme this 1991
movie is a genuinely freaky offering
with actual jump scares you can expect
songs and amazing royal beards the fairy
tale film was produced in Wales and
hungry and the result is pretty far
removed from your typical Disney fare hi
huh wait
Joaquin Phoenix voiced and animated bear
well in that case obviously you're going
to want to watch Brother Bear this 2003
movie is a human to animal
transformation tale till it's perfect
for fans of The Princess and the Frog
there's an important lesson to naturally
but it's good fun with the hunter
getting a good cold dose of karma when
he's lumbered with a talkative cup
there's a 2006 sequel to
Disney's 1996 movie about Quasimodo is
one of its less popular animated
releases but you're missing out if you
skip the Hunchback of Notre Dame it's
worth watching for the Gypsy dancer
Esmeralda alone
you helped me now I will help you but
also for the songs and the storyline of
good guys winning against evil many
viewers will be able to relate to
wanting independence from a mean
government minister to we're now into a
Pixar movie that hasn't garnered as much
attention as the studio's big hitters
this 1998 film features misfit ant flick
who's looking for warriors to save his
colony from grasshoppers but the bugs he
recruits turn out to be a troupe of
circus performers a bug's life is an
important part of the Pixar theory -
which posits that every feature like
Pixar movie is connected if bugs float
your boat then you'll want to get
onboard with ants 1998 was the year for
bug base two feature-length animations
it seems this one features the voice of
Woody Allen as neurotic aunt Z what
about my needs what about me he tries to
break free from his totalitarian society
and win the affection of princess Bala
voiced by Sharon Stone the voice cast
includes Sylvester Stallone Jennifer
Lopez Danny Glover and Dan Aykroyd - the
Prince of Egypt is the first
traditionally animated film produced by
DreamWorks but there's more reason than
just not to watch namely Ralph Fiennes
providing the voice of Ramsay's
impressive in fact this 1998 movie about
Egyptian Prince Moses has a stellar
voice cast all around including Val
Kilmer Michelle Pfeiffer Sandra Bullock
Danny Glover and more what if we told
you that Macaulay Culkin appeared in
animated form in a cartoon movie you
definitely be up for watching that right
and you can thanks to the pagemaster he
stars as a lonely boy that gets trapped
in a world of books in this part live
part animation offering this film from
1994 is as crazy as it sounds
this 1995 movie about the outcast Balto
who's half wolf half husky is totally
relevant to the current global situation
the brave hero risks his life with other
sled dogs to bring medicine to children
in Alaska it's even based on a true
story about an outbreak of D FIRREA in
1925 and yes there are sequels to watch
if you need more Balto when you like
which movie are you most excited to
watch be sure to let us know in the
comments
[Music]